yeah welcome to this video playing the m
hogan here from Spain this guy is
playing be three in every absolutely
every game i already am can I can
anticipate it he's always playing that
it is also if I they often taking this
bishop in situations where you don't
really am don't really expect it and
there's some way to yeah maybe you maybe
this one yeah he obviously has played
this number of times already you can
play all this quickly let's just just
just close this up it's very weird
position but let's see what happens it's
rare in modern chest that after moves
haven't you get a position that with the
almost certainty never ever was reached
before okay I'm I don't like to do it
yeah anyway I need to make sure it
doesn't play you form let's simply block
it
yeah it's it's a very very blocked
position and now he tries to play for
you for maybe maybe I should really
quickly it doesn't pay any attention at
all okay so let's play it for this was
the idea came so move it on is there
some way to sector the bishop probably
not so should I play g5 now or this is
just weakening it is weakening a bit but
it still has still an active means that
aims to to open up the position wait
wait would win if i take Knight takes
and Bishop H form is got an ID f3
hmm
anyway it's probably better to to open
open the position try to get something
on g3 so
Bishop g5 prom me I need to play this
move anyway and some at some point how
to get the rest of the pieces involved
Queenie seven long castles walking this
happen yeah maybe King this happen
actually
he goes Knight to f3 outplay night see
for this is at least I don't know it's
for white this night so yeah it's taking
slide time right here thinking a bit a
bit longer yeah this is what's the
easiest smooth we could have played this
much quicker but anyway and now I'm
threatening actually I was threatening
to take and take on G tool prettier
quite quite nice trick actually go here
King this happening can take on his
successor the knowing thing
okay just let's just prepare long Castle
him
hmm this
yeah maybe you can make a just take take
twice here but till I don't see if
something better I could have taken on
that form maybe this is better of it and
maybe but I think I said I actually
threatened it now taking a group G for
ya since I thank you he probably didn't
take into account wait yeah ok that's it
still smell good
let's assume somehow looks weird to me
for what I mean
I still don't see something good yeah
amazing
there's always 95 blocking blocking it
all
don't see don't see some I don't see
anything great I mean so not even
anything halfway playable yes screw this
up somewhere don't think it was so bad
at the day that is the beginning of all
that yeah this dowser just excellent for
wider
hmm
why why did you need to play this
artificial move don't know
it takes I go if all da time morning no
this is a tricky
check
check
good night you for coming and I'm
download 12 seconds which is the main
problem 94 is why Jack quite a
substantial check check check
check-check
check
checkmate yeah even worse have was seven
seconds this was possible yeah very
lucky very lucky at the end here I'm
just I'm just busted but he played this
far too complicated than necessary
Bishop f5 for example it sir it's a very
easy win him let's just look at this
briefly and set up f5 just this move and
Sam it's just very easy it's a tangy was
check on his 60 I don't really have a
movie and you should take or something
you can also insert that uncheck it's
just two pawns up and and detecting me
even so it's just just completely over
and f5 actually allow so a big
counterplay check and here is a drawn
according to the computer but okay here
check screw this up song right here
check yo call this one here 92 is a draw
yeah this is drawn can take him oh no
this actually winning but he can can't
give her perpetual himself yeah this is
the the point yeah so we basically
probably thinking that he's winning on
time anyway I'm made this mistake and
run into this this hits tamil checks
giving away the Queen in the process
yeah but then I'd like to have a look at
this structure and the computer says
that is SS acceptance was wrong to equal
well I thought so I think I thought that
it should be should be okay
here we are here book g3 and I didn't
really think about that much here it
started to drift into a bad position
yeah of course I saw that I 5s is gone
now but I didn't want to play a passive
news ah this is the computer move yeah
this is a good idea always try to use
the counter play on a 3 and this is
actually equal it needs to protect it
and something like this simply doesn't
keep the pressure on at five so this was
maybe the logical continuation going for
a draw here okay thanks for watching